Are you thinking about getting a plant but worried you don't have the skill set? Well, let's talk about a second option, kids. I feel like there's some steps to be taken. It's a really rapid escalation from like, I'm nervous about plants. I'm going to reproduce. Oh man, that is definitely going to be the intro to this podcast. Oh no, oh no.
你在考虑养一盆植物，但又担心自己没有这方面的技术吗？好吧，我们来聊聊第二个选择，孩子们。我觉得这其中得经历一些步骤。这发展得也太快了，从“我对植物感到紧张”直接跨越到“我要繁衍后代了”。哦天哪，这绝对会成为这个播客的开场白。噢不，噢不。
Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 29, recorded on June 5th, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we have on two guests, Chandler Carruth and Patricia Oss. And in this first episode of our multi-episode series with them, we focus on Chandler's career path leading up to Google. Due to the hectic start of this episode recording, we did not actually get Chandler and Patricia to introduce themselves, so I am briefly going to do that before we hop into things. Chandler Carruth leads the C++, Clang, and LLVM teams at Google and has for many years been an active member of the LLVM and Clang open source communities. Patricia Oss is a C++ programmer with a thing for building browsers. She works for a company that she co-founded called TurtleSec, where she teaches courses in secure coding and C++ and does consulting and contracting, and over the years has been involved
欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 29 期，录制于 2021 年 6 月 5 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天和我一起主持的是布莱斯（Bryce），我们请来了两位嘉宾：钱德勒·卡鲁斯（Chandler Carruth）和帕特里夏·奥斯（Patricia Oss）。在我们与他们的多期系列访谈的第一期中，我们重点探讨了钱德勒进入谷歌之前的职业轨迹。由于本期节目开始时录制过程比较忙乱，我们实际上没有让钱德勒和帕特里夏做自我介绍，所以在我们切入正题之前，我先简单介绍一下他们。钱德勒·卡鲁斯在谷歌领导 C++、Clang 和 LLVM 团队，多年来一直是 LLVM 和 Clang 开源活跃社区的成员。帕特里夏·奥斯是一名 C++ 程序员，对构建浏览器情有独钟。她效力于一家由她联合创立的名叫 TurtleSec 的公司，在那里她教授安全编码和 C++ 课程，并从事咨询和承包业务，多年来她一直参与
in building the Opera and Vivaldi browsers. So with that said, let's hop into things. You're right. So people make fun of this because only in in california do you like solve working from home and like not having a good office space by working outside all year it's like it's like all year long yeah you cannot do that in toronto you cannot do that yeah easy easy flex chandler easy flex we've got great weather here and it's going to last for approximately two months um i've been to toronto i i question the claim that toronto has great weather at any point during the year that's not true it is phenomenally gorgeous out right now yeah same here the weather is absolutely fabulous right now just teasing us because like vacation is still a month out and so by the time we get to like july which is like where we most norwegians do their vacations it's going to be raining all of
构建 Opera 和 Vivaldi 浏览器。好了，闲话少说，我们切入正题吧。你说得对。所以人们对此开玩笑，因为只有在加州，你才会通过一年四季都在室外工作来解决在家办公以及没有一个好的办公空间的问题，就像是，就像是一年四季都可以这样，对，你在多伦多绝对做不到这一点，你在那儿根本做不到，对吧。轻松炫耀啊，钱德勒，真会炫耀。我们这儿天气好极了，而且这种好天气大概能持续两个月。嗯，我去过多伦多，我对“多伦多一年四季中任何时候都有好天气”这种说法表示怀疑。这不是真的，这里现在美得难以置信。是的，我们这儿也一样。现在的天气简直棒极了，只是在逗我们开心，因为离休假还有一个多月，所以当我们迎来七月时——大多数挪威人通常都在七月休假——整个七月都会在下雨
july so it's that is like the the the thing that you take uh for granted the most in california is that like you can just rely on it not raining for a large chunk of the year like the the the sum total of problems i have with my outdoor desk and i have to have a big plastic i actually have a like like like i have an enormous i'm sorry i'm gonna i'm gonna you can cut this out of the podcast if you want i'm gonna i don't think you understand the nature of the podcast this is gold keep going i'm gonna make fun of of like men and dudes for a bit because I got to. I have a big man grill cover because it's like a grill that's so large that you cannot physically operate all of it at a single point in time. I don't know why.
所以，在加州你最容易视作理所当然的事情就是，你可以完全指望这里一年中的很大一部分时间都不会下雨。就像，我那个户外办公桌带来的所有麻烦——我得弄一个巨大的塑料……其实我有一个，就像是一个巨大的……抱歉，我要……如果你愿意的话，可以把这段从播客里剪掉，我要……我觉得你并不了解这个播客的性质，这可是精髓，继续说。我要稍微取笑一下男人们和那些老兄们，因为我非得这么做不可。我有一个很大的男士烧烤炉罩，因为那个烧烤炉实在太大了，你根本无法在任何单一个时间点独自操作它的全部功能。我不知道为什么。
There's some dudes that seem to like feel that if the grill isn't kind of excessively large it's just i'm sorry i'm sorry but i have to come visit you like whenever like we come out of this pandemic i want to see this yard you need to make me something on this grill no i don't have the grill. That's the thing. It's like a reasonably sized grill. Because, like, I don't feel the need to compensate, okay? So I have a reasonably sized grill, but I needed something to cover my outdoor desk. And, like, if you've got a desk with, like, a tall monitor on it, it's kind of shaped like a grill, but just a really freaking large grill. And so I got an enormous grill cover. I had to special order it i think from china or
有些老兄好像觉得，如果烧烤炉不够大得离谱的话……真抱歉，真抱歉，但我一定要去拜访你，等我们熬过这场大流行，我一定要看看这个院子。你得用这个烧烤炉给我做点吃的。不，我没有烧烤炉。这就是问题所在。它只是一个大小合理的烧烤炉。因为，我觉得没必要通过它来补偿什么，好吧？所以我有一个大小合理的烧烤炉，但我需要个东西来盖住我的户外办公桌。而且，如果你有一个摆着高显示器之类的桌子，它的形状其实有点像烧烤炉，只不过是一个超级无敌巨大的烧烤炉。所以我买了一个巨大的烧烤炉罩。我好像还得特意从中国或
somewhere i couldn't even order it on amazon it was very sketchy how how this arrived but like this enormous grill cover and it's hilarious because the only reason i need it like like there's i'm in california there's no rain like like there's no weather at all i did it because of pollen oh you got pollen it has a layer of pollen on it it's like slightly yellow grill cover because of all of the pollen it's just absurd and so you know like this is this is what i need for for my my you know california experience is anti uh is my allergy medicine this is gold this is gonna be like our best podcast ever. This is the Chandler Carruth you did not know
某个地方网购，甚至都没法在亚马逊上买到。这东西是怎么寄到的，过程可疑得很。不过，这个巨大的烧烤炉罩，搞笑的是，我需要它的唯一原因——这里是加州，根本不下雨——这里压根没有什么鬼天气。我买它是为了花粉。哦，你有花粉问题。它上面积了一层花粉，因为所有的花粉，烧烤炉罩都变成微黄色的了。简直荒谬至极。所以你知道的，这就是我为了我的加州体验所需要的东西，那就是抗过敏药。这太绝了，这将成为我们有史以来最棒的播客。这就是那个你以前并不了解、
that you needed to know, but now you know him. I don't know. I think it's going to compete with Sean Parent talking about the times that he dueled with Steve Jobs. I was literally just talking to Kate Gregory yesterday. Sorry? Are we talking pistols or what? Almost.
但现在你不得不了解的钱德勒·卡鲁斯。我不知道。我觉得这可以和肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent）讲述他与史蒂夫·乔布斯决斗的经历一较高下了。我昨天刚跟凯特·格雷戈里（Kate Gregory）聊过。抱歉？我们在谈论手枪决斗还是别的什么？差不多吧。
No, but I guarantee I'm fairly confident that Sean Parent probably has at least one story about doing somebody with pistols. We'll ask him about that next time he's on. I was talking to Kate Gregory yesterday and she was talking about how Sean's stories are so amazing
不，但我敢保证——我有十足的把握——肖恩·帕伦特至少有一个关于用手枪跟人决斗的故事。下次他来的时候，我们得问问他。我昨天跟凯特·格雷戈里聊天时，她提到肖恩的故事是多么精彩，
and I was like oh have you heard of the Steve Jobs ones and she was like no and I was like you gotta check out our episode 28 it's uh yeah we started by just rambling ourselves and now we're just bringing on people with amazing stories have we really done 28 of these? yeah
然后我说：“哦，你听说过史蒂夫·乔布斯的那些故事吗？”她说没有。然后我说：“你一定要去听听我们的第 28 期节目。”是啊，我们一开始只是随便闲扯，现在我们开始邀请那些有着精彩故事的人来做客了。我们真的已经录了 28 期了吗？是的。
we're definitely beating J people with amazing stories and uh yeah yep we're definitely beating jf bastion what a okay but to be fair jf has two small children and uh and his his podcast co-host has i believe three children and one of them is uh or two of them are a set of twins so i think that that they have a little bit more planning preparation to do to put together an episode than us, the two bachelors. I have six plants, though, Bryce, and those take a lot of – I got to water those every once in a while, so I don't know. I don't know.
我们绝对把 J……那些有着精彩故事的人给比下去了，而且——是的，没错，我们绝对把杰夫·巴斯蒂安（JF Bastien）比下去了。好吧，但平心而论，杰夫有两个年幼的孩子，而且他的播客联合主持人有——我相信有三个孩子，其中一个是——或者其中两个是一对双胞胎。所以我觉得，比起我们这两个单身汉，他们在筹备和制作一期节目时，需要做更多的规划和准备工作。不过，布莱斯，我有六盆植物，那些可需要花不少……我得时不时给它们浇水，所以，我不知道。我不知道。
Chandler looking up and rolling his eyes no no i'm looking at the uh the the one indoor plant like container which which has a dead husk in it see you don't look after your plants and they die apparently no see see i'm of the i'm of the philosophy that i'll just pay somebody to look after my plants oh my gosh I don't make that price money I don't know what that will say about me as a potential future parent but not anything
钱德勒抬头并翻了个白眼。不，不，我是在看那个室内植物容器，里面有一具枯萎的植物残骸。看吧，你不好好照顾你的植物，它们就会死掉，显然是这样的。不，你看，我的哲学是，我只会花钱请别人来照顾我的植物。天哪！我可没有布莱斯那么有钱。我不知道这对我作为一个潜在的未来父母来说意味着什么，但绝不是什么
good okay so I all of my plants my entire life I killed every single one of them so this was like a worry of mine when I had children it's like how the hell am I going to do this thing when I can't even keep a plant alive? You know, this is worrisome.
好事。好吧，我这辈子养的所有植物，每一盆都被我养死了。所以当我有了孩子时，这成了我的一大担忧：当连一盆植物都养不活的时候，我到底该怎么养育这小家伙？你知道的，这真让人揪心。
But one of the great things about kids is that if they're hungry, they will scream your head off. Now, if my plants were screaming, they would be alive today. What you're saying is it's the plant's fault. Yes, they would be alive today. So, so I... What you're saying is it's the plant's fault. Yes, they should be screaming more. Somebody should make, like, a little, like, like, a thing that you put into, like, the soil, and when it's too dry, it just blasts,
但养孩子的一大好处是，如果他们饿了，他们会大声哭闹，吵得你头疼。现在，如果我的植物会尖叫，它们今天就能活下来了。你的意思是这怪植物喽？对的，它们今天就能活下来。所以，所以我……你的意思是这怪植物喽？对的，它们应该多尖叫才对。有人应该造个小东西，比如插在土壤里那种，当土壤太干时，它就会发出
like, some really annoying sound. I'm sure there's someone with an Arduino that... Yeah, I'm sure someone's done that uh see also too i feel like we should turn this into an infomercial uh with patricia are you thinking about getting a plant but worried you don't have the skill set well let's talk about a second option i feel like there's some steps to be taken. It's a really rapid escalation from like, I'm nervous about plants.
某种非常烦人的声音。我相信有人用 Arduino 能……对，我相信有人已经做过那玩意儿了。另外我也觉得，我们应该把这变成一个电视购物节目——同帕特里夏一起：你在考虑养一盆植物，但又担心自己没有这方面的技术吗？好吧，我们来聊聊第二个选择。我觉得这其中得经历一些步骤。这发展得也太快了，从“我对植物感到紧张”
I'm going to reproduce. Oh man, that's definitely going to be the intro to this podcast. Oh no. Oh no. All right, so we did have an actual topic right yes I know what the topic is I even have notes that I saw
到“我要繁衍后代了”。哦天哪，这绝对会成为这个播客的开场白。噢不。噢不。好吧，所以我们确实有个真正的主题，对吧？是的，我知道主题是什么，我甚至还有笔记，我看到了。
I saw the twitter dm thread and I know that I probably read it at the time but during the work week like I'm in like project manager mode. So I was just like, OK, Chandler, Patricia, sounds good. So I don't even know what I don't remember, at least what I'm getting myself into. OK, what are we talking about? OK, so so the back story here is that we're like my company.
我看到了 Twitter 私信串，我知道我当时可能读过它，但在工作日里，我处于项目经理模式。所以我的反应就是：好的，钱德勒，帕特里夏，听起来不错。所以我甚至不知道——至少不记得自己究竟卷入了什么。好吧，我们在聊什么？好吧，所以背景是这样的：我们公司——
We're like super tiny. We're three people. And so we're hiring for like the first time. We're doing like public hiring. And I've never really done this. I've participated in interviews where I was just like the girl that you pull into the room. So it's not all dudes. And that was the extent of my experience of doing this. And so now I have to do all of it. But, you know, there are stages to this.
我们规模超级小，只有三个人。所以我们正在进行有生以来第一次招聘。我们正在进行公开招聘。我以前从来没真正做过这个。我以前参加面试时，只是那种被拉进面试房间里的“女员工”，好证明并非全都是男的。这就是我在这方面的全部经验了。而现在，我得把所有这些流程都包揽下来。但是，你知道的，这都是有阶段的。
And next week, I'm coming to the stage where I'm actually going to be speaking to potential people. And I did not have much of an idea what to do. So then I asked on Twitter, what do you ask people to try to figure out if they're nice humans and human-wise fit in? Not tech part, we'll put that aside, but is this a human you want inside of your company kind of thing um and so so then Chandler wrote like this thread like I think it's like four tweets uh and and one and and then I I said oh had done so so so so today we are going to interview chandler
下周，我将进入实际与候选人交谈的阶段。而我当时并没有什么头绪该怎么做。于是我在推特上发问：“你们在面试别人时会问什么问题，来判断他们是不是好人、在人品上是否合得来？”不谈技术部分，我们把那放一边，而是问：这是一个你想迎进公司内部的人吗？诸如此类的问题。然后，钱德勒就写了这么一个长推文串——我想大概有四条推文——然后我说：“哦，太棒了。”所以今天我们要采访钱德勒。
and by we you we mean you patricia i have i have no notes and no questions and help me because i have no idea what i'm doing. So the thing is Chandler knows what he's doing, but he's going to be answering the questions. So should we ask Chandler? Have you, I assume you've been, you have a certain amount of interview experience, interviewer experience. But what's interesting is I have a feeling that Chandler has not been interviewed that many times in his career. Oh yeah. So what's your interviewee versus interviewer experience Chandler has not been interviewed that many times in his career. Oh, yeah. So what's your interviewee versus interviewer experience, Chandler?
“我们”指的是你，帕特里夏。我没有做笔记，也没有准备问题，求求你们帮帮我吧，因为我根本不知道自己在做什么。问题是，钱德勒知道自己在做什么，但他将是那个回答问题的人。那么我们应该问问钱德勒吗？你——我假设你参加过一定数量的面试，有面试官的经验。但有趣的是，我有一种感觉，钱德勒在自己的职业生涯中并没有被面试过很多次。哦，是的。那么，作为应聘者和作为面试官，你的经验对比是怎样的呢，钱德勒？
All right. So let's start there, I guess. So I have – I'm trying to think. I believe that I have interviewed for three jobs. No, four jobs. Wow. In my entire entire life i've done four job interviews that's not four successful like that's just four in total and that that's not even that's not even four tech job interviews that's four no no that's four tech job interviews okay four tech jobs okay but those are the only interviews i've ever done for a job, to be fair. So when I was graduating from university, I was an idiot. To be very clear, I'm not being sarcastic.
好吧。那么我想我们就从这里开始吧。我有——我在努力回想。我相信我只为三份工作面试过。不，四份工作。哇。在我的一生中，我总共只进行过四次工作面试。这倒不是说四次都成功了——我的意思是总共就四次。而且这甚至还不是四次技术工作面试——不是，四次都是技术工作面试。好吧，四份技术工作。不过公平地说，那是我为工作做过的仅有的几次面试。所以当我大学毕业时，我简直是个大笨蛋。为了说清楚起见，我可不是在说反话。
I was an idiot. And I had no plan because I was doing a startup and I thought that this startup was going to be totally awesome. It wasn't. But that's neither here nor there. And so I didn't actually plan when I graduated for a gainful employment of any form. And I thought this would be kind of no big deal. I wasn't stressed about it. And so I just kind of wandered over to the university's kind of IT department where I had been working as a student worker for the past three years. And I was a student worker at their IT department, like on a team. Like I even sat in like cubicles and coded and such.
我当时就是个白痴。我没有任何计划，因为我当时在搞一家初创公司，我以为这家初创公司会超级无敌棒。结果并没有。但这暂且不表。所以当我毕业时，我其实根本没有为任何形式的有薪工作做过规划。我觉得这大概不算什么大不了的事，我一点也不为此感到压力。于是我就溜达着去了大学的 IT 部门，过去三年里我一直以学生工的身份在那里工作。我是他们 IT 部门的一个学生工，在一个团队里。甚至还坐在隔间里写代码什么的。
And they had told me they were hiring a full-time position for the job I had been doing. Um, and so I was like, this is, I'm pretty sure I just got like a fancy shiny computer science degree. Um, this is like a pretty, pretty straightforward it job. This was not like a super difficult job is working on the, you know, university website. Um, and so I showed up and interviewed there. It was the first job interview I'd ever really done. And, you know, I knew everyone already because I'd been working there. And so I knew every single one of my interviewers.
他们曾告诉我，他们正在为一个我一直在做的工作岗位招聘全职员工。所以当时我想，这——我敢肯定我刚刚拿到了一个光鲜亮丽的计算机科学学位。这就像是一份非常非常直截了当的 IT 工作。这并不是什么超级困难的工作，只是在维护大学网站。所以我就去了那里参加面试。那是我这辈子经历过的第一场真正的工作面试。而且，你知道的，因为我已经在那里工作过了，所以我认识每一个人。因此，我的每一位面试官我都认识。
They asked me questions that I kind of expected them to ask me. I answered them. It went fine. And then I didn't get the job. You interviewed for your own job and you didn't get it. Literally, I interviewed for the job I was already doing
他们问了我一些我预料到他们会问的问题。我回答了。一切都很顺利。然后我没得到那份工作。你面试了你本来就在做的工作，结果却没有被录用。真的，我面试的就是我已经在做的工作，
and was rejected. You're giving a lot of people that listen to this podcast hope, Chandler. If this is where Chandler started out, there's hope for all of us so the next job i get i have to admit i didn't have to interview for um so the next job i had was i delivered pizzas for papa john's um after i moved back home um because i did not have gainful employment and and my my very very dear mother if she ever for some reason hears this, my very dear mother took me back in but did insist that I have some form of gainful employment.
然后被拒绝了。钱德勒，你给了听这个播客的许多人带来了希望。如果这就是钱德勒起步的地方，那我们所有人都有希望了。所以我得到的下一份工作，我必须承认，我甚至不需要面试。我拥有的下一份工作是，在搬回老家后，我去了棒约翰（Papa John's）送披萨。因为我没有固定收入，而且我那位非常非常亲爱的妈妈——如果她出于某种原因听到了这个的话——我这位亲爱的妈妈收留了我，但她坚持要求我得有某种形式的固定收入。
And the only job I could get where I grew up was delivering pizzas at Papa John's. I didn't have to interview for that one. I simply had to show up and have a car. If folks don't know how delivering pizzas for a chain like Papa John's goes, I want to be very clear. It is a nightmare. So this is how a chain pizza place works. They're required, usually by local laws and ordinances and things, to have a certain number of employees that are actually paid minimum wage and work in the kitchen. This is usually one or two. In my restaurant's case, it was two. Every other employee is typically a delivery driver. And the reason for this is that delivery drivers by law are tip receiving employees. Because you are eligible to receive tips as part of your job in the U.S.,
在我长大的地方，我唯一能找到的工作就是在棒约翰送披萨。那份工作我不需要面试。我只需要露面，并且有一辆车。如果大家不知道像棒约翰这样的连锁店送披萨是怎么回事的话，我想把话说清楚。那简直是一场噩梦。连锁披萨店的运作方式是这样的：它们通常受到当地法律、法规等的约束，被要求必须有一定数量的员工实际上拿的是最低工资，并且在厨房工作。通常是一两个人。在我打工的那家店里，是两个人。其他所有员工通常都是外卖送餐员。这样做的原因是，送餐员按法律规定是属于拿小费的员工。因为作为在美国工作的一部分，你有资格获得小费，
they don't have to pay you minimum wage. They get to pay you like half of minimum wage. And they can still compel you to work in the kitchen anytime that you don't have deliveries. And so this is why in rural middle of nowhere, where I grew up, we would have two people working in the restaurant making pizzas when we actually needed about four or six, and we would have two people working in the restaurant making pizzas when we actually needed about four six and we would have eight people uh delivering pizzas with scare quotes because the rest of the time they just worked in the kitchen and this is this is how i got a job working in the kitchen for about uh six six eight dollars an hour um uh and then every now and then like the highlight of your night was that you'd get
所以他们不需要付给你最低工资。他们可以只付给你相当于最低工资一半左右的薪水。而且只要你没有外卖要送，他们随时可以强迫你在厨房干活。这就是为什么在我长大的那个鸟不拉屎的乡村，当我们的餐厅实际上需要大约四到六个人时，却只有两个人端坐在店里做披萨；而当我们的餐厅实际上需要大约四到六个人时，却只有两个人端坐在店里做披萨；并且我们会有八个人——加了引号的“送披萨”，因为剩下的时间他们都在厨房干活。这就是我如何得到了一份在厨房工作、时薪大约六到八美元的工作，
you'd finally come up on the rotation to actually deliver some pizzas um but you had to drive your own car that they did not compensate you for and you had to put an enormous papa john's lit sign on top of it with magnets that scratch the paint and it's huge so it hurts your mileage and so your gasoline is actually even more expensive we didn't have fancy electric cars in the middle of nowhere and it's the middle of nowhere and right so i have to drive a long way to deliver these pizzas it usually takes about 20 to 30 minutes of driving to get from the restaurant to uh the first house you can take maybe two orders maybe three orders on a really good night you can get three orders in a single delivery run to collect tips from. And you'll get tips like a dollar because they bought $10 of pizza.
然后偶尔——你当晚的高光时刻就是——你终于在轮班排班中轮到去送几趟披萨了。但你必须开着他们根本不给你报销油费的你自己的车，你还得在车顶上放一个巨大的、带有磁铁的棒约翰发光招牌，那磁铁会刮伤车漆。而且它太大了，会增加风阻，所以你的油耗变得更高，这意味着你的汽油费实际上更贵了。在鸟不拉屎的地方，我们可没有那些高级的电动车。那里是不毛之地，对吧？所以我必须开很远的路去送这些披萨。从餐厅到第一位顾客的家，通常需要开大约 20 到 30 分钟的车。一次送餐跑单，你可能可以带两份订单，运气极好的话，单次送餐可以接三份订单来收集小费。
And very helpfully, Papa John's, the company, not the, and remember like the way restaurants in the US work, you have a company called Papa John's. They do not operate restaurants. What they do is they allow people to pay them to use the Papa John's brand and ingredients and recipes in the restaurant that they run privately. It's a franchising operation. This is so broken and dystopic. This is normal in the U.S., right?
而你拿到的小费大概只有一美元，因为他们只买了两美元的披萨。非常“热心”的是，棒约翰这家公司——注意哦，不是……记住美国餐厅的运作方式：你有一家叫棒约翰的公司。他们不经营餐厅。他们做的是，允许人们付费使用棒约翰的品牌、食材以及他们私下经营的餐厅里的食谱。这是一种特许经营模式。这简直太腐败、太反乌托邦了。在美国这很正常，对吧？
This is actually how – this is capitalism at its finest okay and so so anyways long okay so you okay you you you failed your interview for your university you didn't interview for your pizza no i didn't have to interview for that so so how did you like there's like a dot dot dot and now i'm huge in google i i well so i actually have to finish a little bit of the story so i'm driving i'm delivering pizzas this is like you know a nightmare that i'm living in uh at some point i go down to visit my uh uh uh you know future partner uh uh and we are still together right and so i visit I visit her. She was, she went to the same university. She was a year behind me and she was doing a summer program there.
这实际上就是——这就是资本主义最纯粹的体现。好吧，不管怎样，长话短说……好吧，你——你面试大学工作失败了，你送披萨也没面试——对，我不需要面试。那你是怎么——这里有个省略号，然后我就成了谷歌大牛？我——其实我得把这个故事稍微讲完。所以我在开车送披萨，这就像是——你知道的——我生活在水深火热之中。有一天，我去拜访我那位——嗯——未来的伴侣——我们现在还在一起呢。所以我去看望她。她上的是同一所大学，比我低一年级，当时她正在那里参加一个暑期项目。
And so after I graduated, I went down to visit during the summer. And, you know, I was there for one night, you know, basically squatting in the dormitories of the university because it's not like I could afford a hotel at the time. And then I had to go back and go back to work because it's a two and a half hour drive.
所以我毕业后，趁着夏天去探望她。我在那里待了一晚，基本上是赖在大学宿舍里，因为当时我根本住不起酒店。然后我不得不开车回去上班，因为车程有两个半小时。
And so I start driving out of the university. There's like a hill right out of the university. I'm driving the car out of the university and it makes this really weird noise. Oh no. and then it starts to roll backwards down the road so now so now chandler will lose his job as the pizza driver because he no longer has a car and i literally like so the car broke it was going to cost about uh fifteen hundred dollars to fix my car. I'm at this university. I don't have a place to live. Oh my gosh.
于是我开始把车开出大学校园。大学门口有个斜坡。我开着车驶出校园，车子发出了一种非常奇怪的声音。噢不。然后它开始沿着马路往后倒溜。所以现在——现在钱德勒要失去他送披萨的工作了，因为他再也没有车了。我简直——所以车坏了，修车大约需要 1500 美元。我身处这所大学里，连个住的地方都没有。天哪！
And I'm losing my pizza delivery job because I can't pay to fix my car either. And so I roll my car into one of the parking lots in the university because I can't drive it anywhere and walk back to the dormitory and and begin to squat for real and so i actually like uh um also if by some miracle uh uh my partner's roommate ever hears this uh you you are you are a saint to put up with me squatting in
而且我要失去送披萨的工作了，因为我也付不起修车的钱。于是我把车开进大学的一个停车场里，因为车已经没法开了，然后我走回宿舍，开始真正地赖着不走。实际上我还——另外，如果奇迹般地我伴侣的室友听到了这段话——你真是个圣人，能容忍我在你……
your uh she didn't have her own room in the dormitory either right wow um this is gold man i swatted there for about a month and at one point i was you know uh uh basically the only way we could buy food was i had i had a credit card um um it wasn't even my credit card i couldn't get a good credit card it was was my mother's credit card. This is such a horrible story. But I was walking and I was kind of unsurprisingly bored because I did not have a job. You are homeless. You are jobless.
她当时在宿舍里也没有自己的房间，对吧？哇。这太绝了，老兄。我在那儿赖了一个月左右。当时我唯一的买饭途径就是——我有一张信用卡。甚至都不是我的信用卡，我办不下好一点的信用卡，那是用我妈妈的卡。这个故事太惨了。但我当时在走路，而且不出所料，因为没有工作，我感到很无聊。你无家可归。你失业了。
And you are spending your mother's borrowed money. Yes. And she didn't have money either. She had no hope of paying off this credit card right this was there was not like a solution available but i was walking around because i was bored and i knew everyone in the computer science department i just graduated from there i was walking around and i ran into one of my former professors um dr david john and if he ever hears this like he literally saved my life um so i just ran into him and uh he
你花的是你借来妈妈的钱。是的。而且她也没钱。她根本没有还清这张信用卡的希望。这根本没有解决办法。但我当时因为无聊到处闲逛，而且我认识计算机科学系的每一个人，我刚从那里毕业。我走着走着，遇到了我以前的一位教授——大卫·约翰（David John）博士。如果他听到这个的话——他简直救了我的命。我刚好碰到了他，他
asked how i was doing and you know you know that point in time when you're like you're at you're really at a low point and and you just run into someone that you met when like things were fine and they ask you how are things going there's that like you have that awkward pause like what do i say how can i like i know i don't want to lie to you but like do you want the answer to that question so i i i answered him i tried to kind of you know brush it off but still be honest like well you know things aren't aren't going so well you know i'm actually stuck here because you know i don't i i couldn't get that i couldn't get a job um and and he blinked several times and he was like did you consider going to graduate school and i was like well why would i go to graduate school i need a job like i i like that's not and and he like blinked and paused
问我最近过得怎么样。你知道那种感觉吗？当你处于人生真正的低谷时，你碰巧遇到了一个在一切都还很好的时候认识你的人，他们问你最近过得怎么样。那种时候会有尴尬的停顿：我该说什么？我怎么能——我知道我不想对你撒谎，但你真的想听这个问题的答案吗？所以我回答了他。我试图敷衍过去，但还是要保持诚实：“嗯，你知道的，事情……其实不太顺利。我实际上被困在这里了，因为我……找不到工作。”
and gave me like and again like like he saved my life so i i say this with with all the love in the world right that he blinked and kind of said like to and again i was an idiot it's like you understand that they will pay you to go to graduate school and my brain exploded like this just changed my world and so that's when i applied to go to graduate school um and i i got into graduate school um at the end of the summer um started grad school um had no intention of graduating though because i was an idiot and so i was like oh no this will be fine because now i can keep working on this startup. Like this time, having two years of graduate school TA paychecks to do this startup, this will, this will let us let it really take off. It didn't.
然后他眨了好几下眼睛，问我：“你考虑过读研究生吗？”我当时的反应是：“我为什么要读研究生？我需要一份工作啊。我——我觉得这根本……”然后他眨了眨眼，停顿了一下，对我说了一番话——再次声明，他救了我的命，所以我带着世间所有的爱意这样说——他眨了眨眼，然后说：而且我当时真是个白痴：“难道你不知道他们会付钱让你去读研究生吗？”我的大脑当场爆炸了。这简直颠覆了我的世界。于是我申请去读研究生，
So, so then I worked at the startup for two years while I was in graduate school. And in my last semester before I was supposed to, to graduate, our startup got the big break. And this was actually our biggest break. There was a venture capital event, a venture capital firm in Mountain View, California, that was working with a group of angel investors. Now, I don't know if everyone knows what angel investors are, but for startups, right, you have different phases of investment. And venture capital is like really big money. And so it comes later in the thing. But when you have an idea,
并在那个夏天结束时被研究生院录取。不过我当时根本没打算毕业，因为我脑子瓦特了。所以我当时想：“哦，没关系，这下挺好，因为我可以继续搞那家初创公司了。”这一次，拿着研究生院两年的助教薪水来搞这家初创公司，这绝对、绝对能让它真正腾飞。结果并没有。
you're just trying to get kind of what they call seed money to start your startup. You often get angel investors. And these tend to be, instead of a big venture capital firm, angel investors tend to be individuals, basically wealthy individuals. What's that guy from Silicon Valley with the Three Comma Club? What's his name?
所以，我在读研期间为这家初创公司工作了两年。就在我预计毕业前的最后一个学期，我们的初创公司迎来了重大突破。这实际上是我们最大的突破。当时有一场风险投资活动，加州山景城的一家风险投资公司正在与一群天使投资人合作。现在，我不知道每个人是否都知道什么是天使投资人，但对于初创公司来说，你有不同的投资阶段。风险投资是非常大笔的资金，所以它通常出现在后面阶段。但当你有一个想法时，
He's an angel investor. I mean, and let's be honest. We are talking about tech money. So they're rich white dudes, right? By and large. By and large, yes. And he is white and rich. You're thinking of Russ white dudes, right? By and large. By and large, yes. And that he is white and rich. You're thinking of Russ Hanneman, right?
你只是想筹集他们所谓的“种子资金”来启动你的初创公司，你通常会找天使投资人。这些往往不是大型风险投资机构，天使投资人往往是个人，基本上是有钱人。硅谷里那个搞“三逗号俱乐部”的家伙叫什么名字？他叫什么来着？
Yeah, I think so. I'll find a Russ Hanneman clip and I'll cut it in because he's a character on the show for sure. Nice, nice. Russ Hanneman, true pleasure to meet you. All of a sudden, I'm 22 years young, and I'm worth 1.2B. Now, a couple decades later, I'm worth 1.4. Don't do what you should do. Do what you want. So, I promise, this is actually the story of my next job interview.
他是个天使投资人。我的意思是，咱们老实说。我们谈论的是科技圈的钱。所以他们基本上都是有钱的白男，对吧？大体上是这样的。大体上是的。而且他又白又有钱。你想的是罗斯·汉纳曼（Russ Hanneman），对吧？
There's some buildup here. Okay. You have to understand this is getting cut into two podcasts. What I'm calling this first one. Oh boy. Do I have some, I do. I have some latitude on to like Chandler Chandler and Papa John's or like
对，我想是的。我会找一段罗斯·汉纳曼的剪辑插进来，因为他绝对是剧里的一个角色。不错，不错。罗斯·汉纳曼，很高兴认识你。转眼间，我才 22 岁，身价就达到了 12 亿美元。几十年后的今天，我的身价是 14 亿。别做你该做的事，去做你想做的事。所以我保证，这其实是我下一份工作面试的故事。
the Papa John Chandler. Chandler hits rock bottom. Sure. True. This was, this was, this was pretty bad. So me and the person I was trying to do this startup with, we got this call from this firm.
这里面有些铺垫。好吧。你得明白，这会被剪成两个播客。我把这第一部分叫作……哦天哪。我有没有一些——我有。我有没有一些自主权来决定，比如《钱德勒与棒约翰》或者
And basically, the venture capital firm was working with a group of angel investors to put together kind of a roadshow of early stage video game startup companies uh basically uh like a like a like an industry fair you know like if you go to a conference you go to like go to the like the the like fair area like the expo area go to all the different booths exactly like that except inverted each of the booths was actually people trying to start up a company. And the attendees were the angel investors. They're basically shopping for companies. So was this startup game related?
《披萨小子钱德勒》。《钱德勒跌入人生谷底》。当然。真的，这——这实在是太惨了。所以我和那个一起搞初创公司的人接到了这家公司的电话。
In theory, yes. We were going to build cross-platform video game middleware. So that instead of people taking their Windows game and porting it to mac and and other platforms using things like uh uh what was it trans gaming uh basically wine but commercialized uh to run your your video game on mac and on linux um instead what we would do is we'd give you a C++ toolkit of middleware and this would allow you to write your game in this totally cross platform way and you'd just use build scripts
基本上，那家风险投资公司当时正与一群天使投资人合作，准备筹办一场早期电子游戏初创公司的巡回展示会——基本上就像是一个行业展会，你知道的，就像你去参加一个会议，走进展览区那种集市区域，去各个展位转转。完全就是那样，只不过反过来了：每个展位实际上都是在努力创办公司的人，而与会者则是天使投资人。他们基本上是在像逛街一样物色公司。所以这家初创公司和游戏有关吗？
you'd build for all the platforms it was going to be great by the way did I mention that I was an idiot I had never worked in the games industry I had never done any professional software development I had been rejected from the only job I had ever interviewed at. But somehow I was going to, like, displace the, like, dominant players in the video game middleware industry.
理论上是的。我们要构建跨平台的电子游戏中间件。这样一来，人们就不需要把 Windows 游戏移植到 Mac 和其他平台上，去使用诸如——那是叫什么来着？TransGaming，基本上就是商业化的 Wine，用来在 Mac 和 Linux 上运行你的电子游戏——相反，我们要做的，是为你提供一个 C++ 中间件工具包，这能让你以完全跨平台的方式编写游戏，你只需要使用构建脚本，
But, you know, that's the hubris of youth. Angel investors. The explosive. Yeah, they apparently were, they were apparently like getting this ready and the people running the event looked at the lineup of companies and they said like, this is boring. All of these companies are either like unsurprising or terrible. Please get something more interesting or this event's going to be boring.
就能为所有平台进行构建，这将会非常棒。顺便问一句，我提到过我曾经是个白痴吗？我从来没有在游戏行业工作过，我从来没有做过任何专业的软件开发，我被我参加过的唯一一次工作面试给拒绝了。但不知怎么的，我居然想要取代电子游戏中间件行业里的那些主导玩家。
And so they were looking around for like weirder farther out uh options and they found you know us in you know north carolina um like doing a video game startup and so they called us and and we're like would you like to come in and pitch at our at our investor thing we're like well yes of course we would outcome the credit cards um right we uh bought plane tickets flew out rented a car figured out where mountain view california is uh drove up to uh uh uh this like building at the time i didn't know i knew nothing about anything right I was just complete naivety. This was KPMG's offices in Mountain View. It's like one of the most famous venture capital firms in the world. Didn't know who they were.
但是，你知道的，这就是年轻人的狂妄自大。天使投资人。爆炸性的。是的，他们显然当时正在筹备这个活动，活动的组织者看了看参展公司的名单，然后说：“太无聊了。所有这些公司要么毫无新意，要么糟糕透顶。请找点更有意思的来，否则这个活动会无聊透顶。”
We drive in. There was apparently some miscommunication. And they were just going to let us set up a booth. But we thought we were going to get to pitch. And only five companies were going to actually get up and pitch and like do their do their spiel for the angels and then they they were most companies are just going to have booths we're going to get to actually do uh but we thought we're going to do a pitch and we pulled up the email where they said that we were going to get to do a pitch on on and like like on a laptop and showed it to them there weren't cell phones like
所以他们四处寻找更古怪、更前沿的选择，然后他们在北卡罗来纳州找到了我们——一个在搞游戏初创公司的团队。于是他们打电话给我们，问：“你们愿意来我们的投资人活动上做路演吗？”我们当时想：“哦，当然，我们求之不得。”信用卡掏出来，
this was before the iPhone. I'd show them this thing. And they're like, well, okay, I guess we'll do a sixth presentation. Amazing thing was, the only really amazing part of this whole startup thing was that I got trained, the university I went to had a very bad computer science program. Sorry, folks. But it had a very good business program, like a really good business program. And so they had trained us how to actually pitch really well. So we didn't know what we were doing, and we had a terrible idea, but we could present it really well.
对吧，我们买了机票，飞了过去，租了一辆车，搞清楚加州山景城在哪里，然后开车来到了——当时我一无所知，我对任何事情都一无所知，完全就是单纯的无知。那是 KPMG（毕马威）位于山景城的办公室。那是世界上最著名的风险投资公司之一。我当时根本不知道他们是谁。
And so we actually went last because they squeezed us into the presentation lineup and just stomped on all of the other presentations. Just blew the whole thing out of the water. With a terrible idea. Fantastic. It was a terrible idea. Okay. So they asked us to actually come back the next day
我们开车进去。显然中间出了一些沟通误会。他们原本只是打算让我们搭个展位，但我们以为我们要去进行路演。只有五家公司能真正上台路演，向天使投资人们做他们的推销演讲，大多数公司都只有展位，而我们以为我们能真正做——但我们以为我们要进行路演，于是我们把那封写着我们要进行路演的邮件——在一台笔记本电脑上展示给他们看。当时可没有智能手机，
to a group of investors that were thinking about investing in our company. We were super excited. So we canceled flights, booked new flights, extended our hotel stay. that were thinking about investing in our company we were super excited so we like told we like canceled flights booked new flights extended our hotel stay out came the student credit cards again uh and and so we showed up and then we drove to this like menlo park palace of a house it's like a like it's a house that has its own like business extension to it. And in the business suite, it's not just an office. It's two or three offices with a
这是在 iPhone 问世之前。我把这个展示给他们看。他们的反应是：“好吧，好吧，我想我们可以多加第六个演讲。”神奇的是，整个创业过程中唯一真正神奇的部分是，我受过训练——我上的那所大学的计算机科学专业非常糟糕。抱歉，各位。但它的商业专业非常好，是一个非常顶尖的商业专业。因此他们训练过我们如何真正出色地进行路演。所以我们虽然不知道自己在干什么，而且有个糟糕透顶的想法，但我们的展示能力极佳。
conference room. You have conference rooms in your house, but apparently, if you host angel investor meetups, you do. So it's something you do. So we set up and got ready to present. We're just waiting. There are six investors there, and we're trying to decide, do we start?
所以我们最后压轴登场，因为他们把我们硬塞进了演讲阵容里，结果直接把所有其他的演讲全给秒杀、碾压了。凭着一个糟糕透顶的想法。太棒了。那是个糟糕透顶的想法。好吧。所以他们要求我们第二天回去，
No, no, no, no, no, no. Wait, wait, wait. We have to wait. Wait for half an hour for this other investor to show up. And finally, he rolls in with an earbud. Because back then, the way you could talk on your phone in public was you had one little earbud in. Bluetooth light blinking. It was very 2000s.
去见一群正考虑投资我们公司的投资者。我们超级兴奋。所以我们取消了机票，预订了新机票，延长了酒店住宿时间。正在考虑投资我们的公司，我们超级兴奋。所以我们——取消了机票，预订了新机票，延长了酒店住宿时间，学生信用卡再次出鞘，
He rolls in, listens to his pitch, looks just straight in the eyes and says, I'm going to try and help you out. You will never get this off the ground. And he went on to say, you've never worked in the video game industry.
然后我们赶往门洛帕克（Menlo Park）一栋宛如宫殿般的房子。那是一栋自带商务扩展区的房子。在商务套房里，不只是一个办公室，而是两三个办公室加一个
You don't know what you're talking about. like like you've never worked in the video game industry you don't know what you're talking about the opportunity you've identified is actually real this would be a fantastic business proposition but like i can't invest in you right you you're just not going to be able to succeed at this idea even though like the background of the idea makes a lot of sense. And so we went back to, I went back to North Carolina and I had about three months left in my, uh, master's program. I had not started writing a master's thesis because I had never planned to graduate. I had planned on doing a startup. I had not talked to a single potential employer. Oh. And I just found out that it was going to be impossible to get this startup off the ground.
会议室。你在家里居然有会议室，不过显然，如果你主办天使投资人聚会的话，你就会有。所以这就是你会做的事。于是我们布置好现场，准备开始展示。我们只是在等待。现场有六位投资者，我们正在纠结：我们要开始吗？
Best thing that could have happened, though. Best thing that could have happened. The person was right. He was completely right. So I went back and started writing my master's thesis. I basically wrote nonstop for about two months. Wrote one of the worst master theses i have been for years trying to get my hands on this thing no i think i found it a few years ago
不，不，不，不，不，不。等等，等等，等等。我们得等上半小时，等另一个投资者出现。最后他戴着耳机晃晃悠悠地进来了。因为在那个年代，你在公共场合用手机通话的方式，就是耳朵里塞着一个小耳机。蓝牙指示灯一闪一闪的。非常有 2000 年代的风格。
and i sent it to you and you told me like never share it with anybody you're right i did um it'll be in the show notes folks Oh, gosh. No, please. What was the name of the thesis? I literally do not remember. What was it on? It was on programming language design, obviously. Oh, well, it's relevant. Yeah, I had brand new groundbreaking ideas that had never been thought of before. Remember, this was like in in 2003 2004 never
他晃悠进来，听了我们的路演，直勾勾地盯着我们的眼睛说：“我试着帮你们一把，你们的这个项目绝对做不起来。”接着他又说：“你们从来没有在游戏行业工作过，
been thought of before of what if we represent programs in a structured data format rather than in text this will be groundbreaking for the record i have since learned that like there was research about this dating back to the late 60s anyways uh i'm not defending my... Actually, I did defend my thesis. That's another story. That's a whole different story. Sounds like you're going to... This is going to become a recurring group here.
你们根本不知道自己在说什么。你们发现的市场机会其实是真实的，这会是一个非常棒的商业命题，但我不能投资你们。你们在这个想法上绝对不可能成功，尽管这个想法的背景听起来很有道理。”于是我们回到了——我回到了北卡罗来纳州，我的硕士项目还剩大约三个月。我当时还没有开始写硕士论文，因为我压根没打算毕业。我当时计划的是搞创业。我甚至没有跟任何潜在雇主谈过。哦。然后我刚刚发现，想要让这家初创公司起步是不可能的了。
This is... I can stop story time anytime you all want. But the key thing is interviewing. Yes. You managed to graduate and you got your degree. Well, ish but yes so so okay so so in the last few weeks i had my thesis finished and i was trying to defend it but i then realized that i still did not have a job and i did not want to repeat i did not want to repeat. I did not want to go back to Papa John's. And so I applied for a job at Apple because in between, like, you know, my video game startup company, Terrible Ideas, I'd played with the open source LLVM project and even managed to get an internship out of it.
这个是……只要你们想听，我随时可以停下故事时间。但关键在于面试。是的。你成功毕业了，拿到了学位。好吧，算是吧，不过是的，所以，嗯，所以在过去几周里，我完成了论文，并试图通过答辩，但我随后意识到我依然没有工作，而且我不想重修，我不想重修。我不想回到棒约翰。因此我申请了苹果公司的工作，因为在此期间，你知道的，我的电子游戏初创公司“糟糕的主意”运作期间，我玩过开源的 LLVM 项目，甚至还因此获得过实习机会。
I didn't ever interview for that. I just, like, kind of got an internship out of it and did like a google summer of code for it um and they posted to the lvm mailing list that there was a job opportunity at apple working on working with lvm that's why i applied for this uh i didn't meet any of the qualifications and so i applied for it anyways as as as you as you as you teach people uh patricia right this is the correct thing to do. Yeah. Never pay attention. Well, don't let the listed qualifications and a job keep you from applying for it. There's so many anecdotes where, like, you know, there's some technology that's two years old and they've got some posting saying looking for five years of requirement. And then the person that wrote the open source library is like, I wrote this and I've only got two. So you might want to revisit.
我从来没有为那个面试过。我只是，呃，有点像顺便得到了一个实习机会，并为此做了一个谷歌编程之夏项目，嗯，他们在 llvm 邮件列表里发帖说苹果有一个工作机会，是做 llvm 相关工作的，这就是我申请这个的原因，呃，我不符合任何资格要求，所以我无论如何都申请了，正如，正如你，正如你教导人们的那样，帕特里夏，对吧？这是正确的做法。是的。永远不要注意。好吧，不要让列出的招聘条件和工作阻碍你去申请。有太多的轶事表明，你知道的，某种技术已经诞生两年了，他们却贴出告示要求五年经验。然后那个开源库的作者就会说，这个是我写的，而我只有两年经验。所以你可能想要重新考虑一下。
Might have to adjust. Yeah. That was the thing when we posted our ad that I didn't want to put in anything. So the whole theory of the ad part of it was to not require anything we weren't prepared to train for. So we are not prepared to train you to become a programmer. So if you cannot program, then we cannot have you because I can't teach you to program.
可能得调整一下。是的。这就是我们发布广告时的情况，我不想在里面加任何要求。所以广告部分的整个理论就是，不要求任何我们没有准备好培训的技能。所以我们没有准备好培训你成为一名程序员。因此，如果你不会编程，那我们就不能录用你，因为我无法教你编程。
But this is like, so the position is basically a programmer with an interest in security in some way. And then I was like like you don't need any experience in security that we we can train you for but you have to be a programmer so you have to know how to code so and outside of that we don't care about programming language whatever just come and you know that that's you we'll we'll see we'll evaluate whatever we get so the idea here was to keep the list as short as possible to encourage more people that are more hesitant than chandler uh to to apply
但情况是这样的，所以这个职位基本上是一个对安全方面某种程度感兴趣的程序员。然后我就想，你不需要任何安全方面的经验，我们可以为你培训，但你必须是一名程序员，所以你必须知道如何编写代码，除此之外，我们不在乎编程语言是什么，随便什么语言，只要来，你知道的，我们会看看，我们会评估我们收到的任何情况。所以这里的想法是把要求列表保持得尽可能短，以鼓励更多比钱德勒更犹豫不决的人来申请。
to be fair this was not like confidence or boldness this was desperation sheer desperation this was fear of papa john, basically. Yes. And so the week before I defended my thesis, the interview got scheduled. And so unfortunately, so I remember I was like, I kind of started halfway through a semester. And so this was actually coming up
平心而论，这不是什么自信或大胆，这是绝望，纯粹的绝望，基本上是对棒约翰的恐惧。是的。所以在论文答辩的前一周，面试安排好了。因此，不幸的是，我记得我是学期中途开始的。所以这实际上快要到了……
on December. And so this was coming up on winter holiday season in the US. And the recruiter at Apple was very clear that it was essential that I interview before everyone left for the holidays. Because he thought that the kind of budget for hiring might be going away and there might be pressure to hire before so i needed to get to california interview at apple and they were going to make a decision hire or not um uh before people left for the holidays and so i i was going to so the the scary thing for me is you know this is the week before i defend my my master's thesis which is really bad, and I know that it's really bad.
在十二月。所以这快要到美国的寒假了。苹果的招聘人员说得很清楚，至关重要的是我必须在所有人放假离开之前完成面试。因为他认为招聘预算可能会消失，而且可能存在提前招聘的压力，所以我需要去加州在苹果面试，他们要在人们放假离开之前做出录用或不录用的决定。嗯，呃，所以我打算去。对我来说可怕的事情是，你知道，这是我硕士论文答辩的前一周，这真的很糟糕，而且我知道这真的很糟糕。
And they need me to interview that week. So I'm going to defend my master's thesis on Monday morning, or Monday afternoon, and they need me to interview on Wednesday so that they can make a decision by the end of that week, because that's the last reliable work week before people start going off to holiday. This is also why I was defending my thesis that week. It was the same reason, right? And so the week before this, I'm on the LLVM IRC channel. And I mentioned that I'm going to be in California because, like, Apple is interviewing me and they're flying me out to California on Tuesday to interview.
而且他们需要我在那一周面试。所以我要在周一早上或周一下午进行硕士论文答辩，他们需要我在周三面试，以便他们能在那个周末结束前做出决定，因为那是大家开始放假前的最后一个可靠工作周。这也是我那周进行论文答辩的原因。是同一个原因，对吧？所以在前一周，我在 LLVM IRC 频道上。我提到我要去加州，因为，呃，苹果在面试我，他们在周二用飞机把我送到加州去面试。
And I get a private message from someone else in the LLVM community who works at Google. And he's like, did you submit a resume to Google? And I was like, no, why would I submit a resume to Google? I don't think that Apple's going to hire me. Why would I, like, try and get hired at Google? And Google isn't even using LLVM. What? How is this even relevant?
然后我收到了 LLVM 社区中另一个在谷歌工作的人的私信。他问，你给谷歌提交简历了吗？我说，没有，我为什么要把简历提交给谷歌？我不认为苹果会录用我。我为什么还要试图去谷歌应聘？而且谷歌甚至没有在使用 LLVM。什么？这怎么能扯上关系呢？
I feel like you keep falling into massive opportunities. Like, you just, like, walk, and there's, like, a hole, and you're, like, poof. I'm a paid graduate student. Poof. I'm on Google. It's like, what is this? I really don't know how this happened. Like, and so I say, like, whatever. And so I sent him my resume.
我觉得你一直在陷入巨大的机遇之中。就像你只是，呃，走着，然后前面有个洞，然后你就，噗。我是一个带薪研究生。噗。我在谷歌。这算什么？我真的不知道这是怎么发生的。就像，所以我说，管他呢。然后我把简历发给了他。
I didn't think anything of it. Continue to get ready to defend my thesis. Okay. So Monday, I defend my thesis. There's a whole story about how I actually got through that. Anyways, but I defend my thesis Monday afternoon, like 1pm, right? By 3pm, I'm like sitting around waiting to hear back from the committee about how many edits they're going to want. Uh, the committee comes back and they want no edits translation. They did not read the thesis. Um, uh, they, they, they want me gone. Um, and, and I understand that frankly, I was not a good student. Um, and 6 p.m., I get a phone call. And the phone call is from the recruiter at Google. And I was like, hi.
我没想太多。继续准备我的论文答辩。好吧。周一，我进行了论文答辩。这里有一个关于我是如何熬过那一关的故事。无论如何，我在周一下午大约一点钟完成了论文答辩，对吧？到了三点钟，我坐在那里等着委员会关于他们需要多少修改意见的回复。呃，委员会回来了，他们不需要任何修改。换句话说，他们没有阅读这篇论文。呃，呃，他们，他们，他们希望我离开。呃，坦白说我理解，我不是个好学生。呃，下午六点，我接到一个电话。打电话来的是谷歌的招聘人员，我说，你好。
Oh, and I've messed up the previous story. So I was supposed to interview on Thursday at Apple, not on Wednesday. Thursday. And then they're going to make a decision on Friday. So I'm on the phone at 6 p.m. on Monday with the Google recruiter. And they're like, no, no, we want to interview you too. I was like, I mean, okay, but Apple is interviewing me on Thursday of this week. And they are saying that they will have a decision on Friday.
哦，我把前面的故事搞混了。所以我原本应该在周四在苹果面试，而不是周三。周四。然后他们会在周五做出决定。所以我周一晚上六点在和谷歌的招聘人员通话。他们说，不，不，我们也想面试你。我说，我的意思是，好吧，但苹果这周四要面试我。而且他们说他们会在周五做出决定。
And I can't say no. If it's the only job I have, I will have to say yes. Like, there's no question. The alternative is pop the job so so the google recruiter says like no we can make this work i've booked so we'll just take over the first half of your flight i have a flight booked for tomorrow to california we'll interview on wednesday you can then like switch hotels and then interview at Apple on Thursday. And then we can both get back to you on Friday. And I'm like, you can do that?
我不能拒绝。如果这是我唯一的工作，我将不得不说“好”。这是毫无疑问的。唯一的选择就是棒约翰。所以谷歌的招聘人员说，不，我们可以解决这个问题，我已经订好了，我们只用占掉你航班的前半段，我订好了明天去加州的机票，我们周三面试，然后你可以换个酒店，周四在苹果面试。然后我们都可以赶在周五给你答复。我说，你们能做到这一点？
Again, I was an idiot. I knew nothing. I had no idea how rare this was even at Google at the time. But of course I said yes, because Papa John's, right? And so I still have to do a bunch of work for my thesis. So you have to like print out your thesis on very special paper in a very special format and like put them in special folders and you have to have a certain number of copies and you have to have your graduate school committee sign like all of them and then you have to submit them to the graduate school by a certain time in order to actually get your degree. And so I spend basically every waking hour from that moment either putting things into a suitcase,
再次强调，我当时就是个白痴。我什么都不懂。当时我根本不知道这在谷歌有多罕见。但当然我答应了，因为棒约翰，对吧？所以我还得为我的论文做一大堆工作。所以你得把论文打印在非常特殊的纸张上，用非常特殊的格式，然后把它们放进特殊的文件夹里，你必须有一定数量的副本，你必须让你的研究生院委员会在所有副本上签字，然后你必须在某个时间之前将它们提交给研究生院，以便真正获得你的学位。因此，从那一刻起，我醒着的每一分钟基本上都在把东西塞进手提箱，
that was easy, I didn't have much, or printing my thesis. I take the thesis to the graduate school, walk out the door to like my friend's car that's waiting at the curb to drive me to the airport so I can make it to my flight. Make it to my flight, and then I get the two other job interviews that I've ever really had. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed, and stay tuned for next week's episode
那很简单，我没有多少东西，或者在打印我的论文。我把论文拿到研究生院，走出大门，坐上在马路牙子旁等我的朋友的车，车送我去机场以便赶上航班。赶上航班，然后我迎来了我人生中仅有的另外两次真正的求职面试。感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，请继续关注下周的节目
where we find out what happened at Chandler's Apple and Google interviews. Have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们将揭晓钱德勒在苹果和谷歌面试中发生了什么。祝你有美好的一天。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。